I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored
Andrew Tate is one of the most
influential men in the world he's a
businessman a mogul and to many people a
misogynist well since last year he's
also practicing Muslim and as Israel
wages war on Hamas he stirred his
followers with furious trades against
Israel's response to the October 7th
attacks tonight I put those views to the
test why do you support heras I support
Justice in the univers support Justice
in the universe you support Hamas no and
for the first time his brother and
Confidant Tristan who's facing the same
very serious criminal charges joins me
and is also uncensor what don't you like
about his views well the the major
[Music]
one I want to turn to the war between
Israel and Hamas in Gaza what is your
view of this War I think when you call
it a warrior doing a disservice to the
people who are having their limbs blown
off by some of the most advanced
technical Weaponry on the planet it is a
genocide and it is disgusting and it
doesn't matter which side of the
political Spectrum you fall on When You
observe a genocide in front of your very
eyes you should be disgusting which side
is waging genocide the Israelis are
genociding the Palestinians and you know
it as well as everybody else well then
it seems like you're bosses are not
allowing you to know it what do you
think of of what Hamas did on October
the 7th why are you starting the story
in the middle I just asked you about the
wider War I'm now asking I Prof I cannot
professionally answer that question
without talking about the context that
led up to October 7th well nothing to my
mind justifies what happened in October
the 7th nothing justifies what happened
before October the 7th appears this the
exact point so you're talking to a man I
don't know what answer you expect from
me cuz let's forget the fact that I'm a
Muslim you're talking to a man who is
fighting oppression to the best of his
ability because he believes that the
people in charge of the world are
enslaving us all to the point where I
detriment my own life I end up at a jail
cell because I'm speak against
oppression then you're asking me what I
would do if my family was blown to pie
you're not in a jail hang you're asking
me what I would do if another government
came along and blew my family to pieces
you weren't put in a jail cell because
of Any oppression absolutely I was no
you weren't of you were put in jail cell
because you've been accused of serious
sexual I would not have been accused if
I was not monumentally successful in
speaking the truth let me ask you again
it's a simple question some people can
answer it straight away including Pro
Palestinians people I've had on my
program many are very quick to say
absolutely do you believe Hamas are a
terror organization and that's a very
interesting question but I think you're
pedaling Asin nities we just answer the
question can somebody do me a favor
Google asini and find out if it's a I
know it means if it's not make sure it's
added to Webster on top G's orders just
are they a terror group you're pedaling
Asin nities because I'll tell you why
Pierce let me answer the question of
course you are a simple question let
like me asking I tell you why I asked
because the UK where you were born
prescribes herass as a terror they also
prescribe me as dangerous to children in
schools let me explain something to you
Pi you're not prescribed as that if I
would sit here and say is stealing wrong
and you'd say yes and I go ah but what
if the person stealing is trying to feed
their family and if they don't their
family are going to die is it still
wrong you're trying to take a very
nuanced and complicated argument and
reduce it down to one sentence which is
failure you're trying to equate stealing
with a mob of terrorists breaking over a
border going to Peaceful is what Israel
did wait a minute a mob of terrorist
breaking over bers and killing people is
that going through a border on October
the 7th oh October the 7th
massacring young people at a festival
massacring families in their homes and a
setting fire to them cutting their heads
off killing babies Oh killing babies
that was true well fine were the babies
vaccinated why are you being flippant
I'm not being flippant the point I am
making I find fun no but the point I
making is that the media lies firstly
secondly I can ask you we can ask I can
ask you about different things at the
same time right so I'm asking you first
of all specifically what is your
reaction to what happened in October the
7th sure I'll answer the question
professionally I do not condone the loss
of human life on either side I think
anybody doing anything which directly
damages civilians is disgusting and
abhorent however I would be an amateur
if I could not sit and pretend I do not
understand the motivations behind either
side this is not even me taking a side I
understand why Israel is doing what is
doing I understand why Palestine is
doing what it's doing however I still
call the Israeli actions absolutely
abhorent and genocidal okay we're going
to come to Israel's actions I promise
you we will ask that question
specifically but in terms of what Hamas
did on October the 7th do you accept
that was an act of terrorism it's an
interesting question because once not
really it isight because you're the
person who would have called Nelson
Mandela a terrorist while he was still
in jail and one person's terrorist is
another person's Freedom fire for me to
answer the question yes you would have
for for me to answer the question I have
to be very professional Pierce for me to
sit on the outside in Romania with no
personal involvement in Israel Palestine
it's easy for me to say yes it was an of
Terror however if I was in Gaza if I was
in an open air prison if my family had
been annihilated by bombs from the sky
if everybody I knew had suffered the
loss of a loved one if I had no chance
of any kind of Freedom or democracy or
standard of life would I believe it was
an act of Terror or would I believe it's
an act of resistance against oppression
you have to be very careful how you
answer these question what do you think
I think I understand what happens when
you take people and put them in such an
inhumane condition for anybody to sit
and say that you're going to take people
and put them in absolutely inhumane
conditions and give them no standard of
life and they're not allowed to ever
fight back or they are ter I can agree
with anyone who does is an amateur I can
agree with you that the plight of the
Palestinians for many decades has been
absolutely shameful what did we think
was going to happen Pierce no nothing
justifies what happened October 7 what
are they supposed to do nothing so what
are they supposed to do that was an act
of medieval barbaric terrorism nothing
justifies did they
suffer toate did they suffer acts of
medieval barbaric terrorism before that
date yes and it's unfortunately an eye
for an eye in this world I'm not
condoning I'm being a professional and
answering give one example let me tell
you the reality of the world what Hamas
did was an act of Terror an absolutely
despicable Act of Terror and should be
called exactly what it is and they are
now demonstrably a terrorist group that
is why they were rightly prescribed that
by the UK and America and other
countries and to try and pretend they're
not makes you sound like Jeremy Corbin
and I can't give a worse in to throw at
you right so I don't think me and would
agree on but I also think there are
legitimate questions to come about the
way Israel's responded we can come to
that but I just want to ask you one more
time is what Hamas did on October 7th an
act of terrorism I think pierce it is
pedling Asin enties for you to pretend
that enslaving you sound like Jeremy
Corbin no let me answer the question 15
times he refused to answer the question
let me answer the question you're now
upus you're now about three or four if
you are they a terror group or not they
one team freedom fighter and they are
deemed a terrorist grp what do you think
I think that if you lock people in an
open air prison and steal their land
they're going to retaliate so they're
not a terror group I think they're going
to retaliate they're not a terror group
one team's terrorist is we're now about
eight are they a terror group and also
another thing I want to make clear to
you only Jeremy Corbin has done this
done what refuse to answer the question
I think that what they are doing is
seemly deemed an act of Terror by the
people that the Terr don't use weasly
words they're not weasly of course the
Israelis think they're a terror group
and of course some of course the
Palestinians think they're Freedom
Fighters most stupid that you're asking
the question most of the Civilized world
thinks they a terror group Committed an
act of terrorism it's not difficult what
they did was an act of terrorism and I
think that if Israel continues to to
conduct acts of terrorism on the
Palestinian people they're going to do
nothing but strengthen the reaction I'm
that's a different conversation I'm
about to have with you about Israel's
response but before I get there one more
time is Hamas a terror group who
committed an act of terrorism I think
that when you lock people in an open air
prison you're going to have to
retaliation no because I to there's
people who are firstly first things I
want to say per do you don't mind me
saying I think it's spineless sure I do
that's fine you sound like Jeremy Corbin
well that that isn't did you see my
interview with him no right 15 times
last week I asked him the same question
15 times he prevaricated and wouldn't
answer eventually when someone does that
enough times you know what they really
think you don't think they're a terror
group let me you don't think they're a
terror group no what I think is this on
certain i' be really curious what you
think an act of Terror is if it's not
massacring 1,500 innocent people
including Holocaust Survivors kidnapping
babies decapitating people cutting their
limbs off raping women yeah talk about
missing limbs we're going to talk about
that when we talk about what done but
when we get there it'll be in the
context of you not admitting that was an
act of ter let me answer the question
for the final time I am a realist and as
a realist sometimes you do not come to
the conclusion of labeling good guys and
bad guys the world is not black and
white bad guys the world is not black
and white the world is actually very
gray anybody who sit and thinks there's
clearly
a good guy and clearly a bad guy does
not understand how the world works and
as a realist what you do is you look at
scenarios and you understand why they
happen how unfortunate they are how
unfortunate the loss of human life is
how civilians die on both sides how
Innocents are dying in a chess game
played by the elites on both sides both
sides you have innocent people who
didn't even vote for the person making
the decisions who are insuring their
death signing their death warrants it's
unfortunate on both sides okay but
listen sir you would not Advocate Russia
doing any of the things to Ukraine that
Israel is doing to to to to Palestine
you would not Russia has been doing
exactly that Russia has not done a
fraction
of Israel has done pal R Russia
illegally invaded a sovereign Democratic
country and has committed a barbaric
Rampage trying to seize as much of
Ukraine as it can bombing maternity
hospitals killing innocent women and
children right don't even try and have
some kind of this is Gen this I will a
Hamas rocket a tiny Hamas rocket that
can make a pothole in the road and then
they get hit back with cruise missiles
let me ask you a question Ukraine sent a
drone and it hit the Kremlin a drone
attack it did nothing it damaged some
some shingles if if Russia decided to
then respond with a missile attack on a
hospital and annihilate 800 people do
you think that would be allowed exactly
what it has been would you advocate for
have you seen would you support that
have you seen the state of marle which
they level to the ground the ukrainians
did level correct no the Russian 2014
the Russian Mar and and my question to
you is would you Advocate those
reactions let me ask you another
question this is a genuine question let
me ask you a question because I want to
understand your point of VI actually my
interview of you yeah but but you tried
to understand mine I just want to
understand your point of view if if I
believed or if Israel believed that one
of the people in your house was a
terrorist and decided to destroy your
entire house and kill your entire family
would you sit and say well maybe there
was a terrorist inside I accept that or
would you be enraged genuine question I
don't think you can take an individual
person's response well it's a bunch of
individual people in Gaza they're people
individuals with thoughts and dreams and
aspirations which are being annihilated
15-year-old girls without legs of cruise
Miss they are individual people they're
not cattle's to people right and so with
the people in Israel October the and
that's why it's so heinous which is my
exact point but not heinous enough to
reach your bar of terrorism about reach
bar of terrorism it's understanding why
things happen by not saying it you've
made your position clear just as Jeremy
Corbin did and to pretend you're any
different is
ridiculous we're here thanks for joining
us you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all soon Act
sella
gon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella Bradman she's heading
up one side and richy soon had the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to no whether
it's a FSE or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased new is
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hamas
stay in power and are there a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that let's move on to Israel's response
because there are legitimate questions
about this Hamas embeds itself 35 40,000
terrorists in my estimation you can call
them whatever you like um
and they're embedded amongst the
civilian population predominantly in
Northern Gaza they we know from
intelligence over the last 20 years
intelligence which you won't believe
because the Matrix has made it all up we
know from intelligence that historically
Hamas likes to embed itself particularly
around things like schools and hospitals
and mosque because that makes it more
difficult if the Israelis attack yeah
now Israel has killed nearly 12,000
people in its response right there are
many people around the world demanding a
ceasefire who think that that is a
ridiculously disproportionate response
to what happened well it was genocide
they would want to kill everyone in
Palestine they don't they just want to
drive them all out whereas Hamas do want
to kill every Jew that is actually what
genocide is you know what's actually
interesting because you've spoken about
this subject of people more who actually
understand the conflict better than I do
Muhammad hij understands it better Loki
understands it better I'm talking from a
very general humanistic perspective
because I don't understand that absolute
intricacies like they do do you know
what genocide means of course I do right
genocide means you want to eradicate an
hire people based on racial ethnicity
Israel clearly doesn't want to do that
to the Palestinian people if it did it
wouldn't tell a million of them as it
turned out who Moved South now there are
arguments about whether to attack them
as they moved well some people got hit
as they moved oh some people got hit
some people got hit you you know what
happens you wait till it's your son wait
it's your son I agree and you know what
Andrew war is horrific it's horrific the
question is is it a just War for Israel
to go after Hamas and if it is and you
believe as I do that aass has to be got
rid of how do you do that if you don't
do it the way Israel is is doing it how
do you get rid of that terror group now
you won't agree with anything they're
doing because you can't even categorize
them as a terror group no the reason I
won't agree with him is because I'm a
human Pierce and please let me answer
this without being interrupted you
didn't answer my earlier question for a
reason because you knew that you
couldn't answer it without which my
point the question about the fact that
if they decided to cruise missile your
house because they thought somebody
inside was a terrorist you would not
accept the loss of your family that you
have raised you would not accept that
okay absolutely so let me answer this as
a
professional what's funny is I'm a
humanist like I professional what by the
way a Prof the professional please let
me answer let me answer what are you
what are you speak You're speak
professional and I'm talking about this
from a humanistic perspective right and
like I said you've talked about you've
talked to people more know knowledgeable
than me on the details of the subject
listen to me very carefully I thought we
lived in a Democratic Society you just
had 35,000 Hamas terrorists and this is
the thing that's most upsetting to me
this is what genuinely upsets me Israel
intelligence will say a guy's a Hamas
terrorist has that guy gone to a court
of law has there been a democratic
process has he been proven to be a
terrorist no they've just decided from
their intelligence that couldn't see an
invasion coming from hundreds of miles
away so this intelligence is it's not
it's not great so they've decided this
person might be in intelligence without
court case without any kind of
democratic process and because of that
they've decided to annihilate civilians
along with him and it's all just
collateral damage and nobody should care
that is not a humanistic perspective and
that is disgusting and any person in the
west who is advocating for that is a
hypocrite if it was turned on them if
the American government said we think
the person in your shopping mall one of
the people you were shopping alongside
in the mall might have committed a crime
we didn't take them to court we think
they might have so he killed your whole
family get over it is a clown and a
hypocrite so the last time what do you
expect grown men to do to respond what
do you expect full grown men to do when
you kill all of their families and leave
them locked in an open airon resp last
time that Jewish people faced an
existential threat was in World War II
and the Nazis who wanted to take over
the world and kill every Jewish person
the Nazis were ultimately defeated by
Winston Churchill leading the allies and
Winston Churchill in the process of
defeating the Nazis killed a lot of
German innocent civilians in the process
do you think that was justified let me
ask a question was it well no I ask the
questions was it Justified sir I believe
and let just get this right in my head
yeah think about it no I don't need to
think about your question I believe that
the Nazis which were obviously heinous
I'm not advocating anything they do it's
disgusting the nais I'm glad we beat
them I'm actually a huge were they
terrorist yeah they were right so I
believe that they so when you Massacre
Jewish people you're terrorists except
when you do it in Israel when you try
and conduct genocide on a populist
because you don't want them on land you
say is yours then you are terrorist
that's exactly what Hamas did on October
Israel had did before that so you've
literally just described what Hamas do
you just describe what Israel do they're
trying to genocide the Palestinians as
we speak and this is the exact point to
no but to sit so you think Israel a
terrorists I think that what they're
doing now is disproportionate in
genocide Terris it's genocidal so I
guess that makes it terrorism it's genal
so they're terrorists for responding to
an act of Terror but the people who
committed the act of Terror are not
terrorists the way in which they're
responding you see the problem in that
argument no I really I pierce what they
are doing now slaughtering 1500 people
in the way they did it is not an act of
Terror by terrorists but a response from
the people on the receiving end rather
like the response of the Allies in World
War to what the Nazis did that
apparently is the only Act of terrorism
didn't you say 12,000 people the
Israelis have killed thus far yes I saw
a video of a 15-year-old girl with no
legs begging to die yeah she was begging
to die saying I have no future CU my
parents are gone or my legs are gone I
have no future no but you say that right
you talk about numbers and statistics
and you say a few people got caught you
don't think of gazin and you don't think
of as Muslims and Palestinian as
individual people oh yes I do no you
don't because if you did if you if you
did you be happy with you dare say that
about me okay then don't together in
numbers I've spoken for many years about
the pl of the Palestinian people I think
it's outrageous that Israel has any
control over their ability to function
with water with fuel with uh other
energy and so on food and that's
interesting if you were in Gaza as a
gazan male of masculine fighting age and
you believe the things you L believe
what would you do about it I'm just
asking you know what nothing justifies
the terrorism we never you be a
terrorist I'm asking what you do no I
understand why people in Palestine feel
oppressed I understand why they want
freedom I understand why they want the
same rights as the people in Israel then
here's a perfect on that we
agree but nothing nothing justifies what
happened in October well here's where we
here's where we disagree per because as
a professional when we both agree on the
point that the people inside of Gaza are
being oppressed and that their life is
being detriment and that they have no
way of getting out we as a professional
I agree with that I understand pressure
cookers explode you're pretending they
shouldn't you're saying that they should
never explode nothing bad should ever
happen we should just be allowed to
subjugate them for Endless years and
nothing happen and I'm a realist to
understand that pressure cookers explode
and that's what happen we need a
solution to the problem or it will
continue to happen you're not a realist
because actually you are not accepting
that what they did October the 7th was
an act of terrorism by terrorists you
won't accept that you think actually
their freedom fights is doing some kind
of resistance and I say that is
ridiculous and shameful that's the
difference between us I understand that
pressure cooker exploders right so you
think it's perfectly reasonable what
happened then I don't think it's
reasonable I think it's I think it's a
shame natural consequence I think it's a
shame a shame that's it I think I think
it's a shame that we're living in the
world now where people are reduced to
basically suicide to try and fight for
freedom for their families if they have
one left because they all committed
suicide those men who did that they
didn't have they didn't have a chance of
survival I think when you that's because
that's because they believe that they're
marching themselves are going to better
life you oppress people to the point
where their family is dead and they have
nothing to live for I think that's a
shame so you do you support Islamic
fundamentalism absolutely not you
support an islamist ideology absolutely
not right what I support so why do you
support Hamas I support Justice in the
univers I support Justice in the
universe you support Hamas no you don't
well I don't know the ins and outs of
hamas's creed I have to be very honest
you know what they did in October the
7th you support them I understand why
that happened and I'm it's a shame but
you won't denounce them I say it's a
shame will you condemn them I'm I I
can't sit here and condemn the obvious
outcome of of consequence really how can
I cond you can't condemn Hamas for what
they did well we know what's going to
happen and we need a solution you're
very quick to condemn Israel's response
but you won't condemn the terror attack
which prompted it no I'll tell you why
even though Hamas Knew by doing what
they were doing that would be the
response do you think they knew that of
course they knew that you think they
knew the Israel they did it quite
deliberately you know why because they
were fun fed and supported by Iran they
didn't like the fact that Israel was
normalizing relations with a bunch of
Arab countries from the UAE to Bahrain
to Morocco and then coming down the line
was going to be Saudi Arabia that was a
threat to the Iran view of what should
be happening in that region Iran are the
ones who support and fund and arm Hamas
and they clearly in my estimation Al it
hasn't been proberly established yet but
clearly Hamas couldn't have done this on
their own they've done it with support
from Iran and they've gone and and
committed an act of such Heat atrocity
that they knew what the response would
be and that means that they sentenced in
that moment not just 1500 people in
Israel to death in the most appalling
manner possible but they also sentenced
to death thousands and thousands of
innocent Palestinians including many
innocent children because half the
population had children and Hamas knew
that was what was going to happen so my
question is how can anyone think that
Hamas is a Force for
good for good I said I said they're
unfortunate no I didn't say they're a
Force for good I said it's a press
cooker and it's a shame you let me ask
let me ask the question do you think if
we gave the Palestinian people basic
human rights that Hamas would find it
more difficult to recruit new
soldiers uh I yeah I think probably
probably if we treat them like humans
this won't happen so we agree and let's
move on I think there's a real danger in
the scale of Israel's response that you
radicalize a whole new generation of
Palestinians I think that's a real
danger by the way I've said that we can
agree on that so perhaps it was Israel's
actions before October 7th that
radicalizes sold who invaded so you
agree with me so let's move no I don't
no nothing justifies nothing justifies
what they
did we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
you know what I love about talk today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes R expected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
unit which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem himself when I say
I am God I'm not joking did you feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
question are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible a
Ral talk TV is the only place where you
get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV let me ask you about the reaction
that you've had from uh certain people
who I think at one stage uh you had a
good relationship with one is um Jordan
Peterson and the other one Ben Shapiro
let's talk about Jordan first sure
you've had a bit of a two and fr with
him but what is your view of him I think
Jordan and I actually agree on many
issues I think the enemy of my enemy is
my friend I think we have a lot more in
common than we have that we disagree on
we have different views of the world on
certain things I think we approach him
from different places he's far more in
his mind where that even more in a
Physical Realm than he does I have
nothing against Jordan I don't dislike
him I do find it and I must be honest a
bit disingenuous and hypocritical that
he speaks mental strength and then ends
up addicted to an anti-depressant I
don't think he should ever take
anti-depressants ever I've been through
worse than what he's been through and I
didn't take a single drug however I have
nothing against the guy he says very
intelligent things and I'd be interested
to argue with him or discuss or debate
with him but I think we'd actually agree
on most points to be honest with you I
don't think we I mean he may be unhappy
with somehow how I've lived my life and
some things I've done but we've already
discussed the fact that I come from the
lowest income area of the UK and most
people around me were selling drugs so
at least I didn't do that so I'm not
going to allow somebody who's a
professor in a university who's had an
easy life come along and tell me how
people from the streets should survive
you have to find a way out let's get
Richard D trying but I have nothing
against the guy I just think that he's
been a bit hypocritical and then
truthfully the only time I've been
genuinely a bit appalled by any of his
actions was the Tweet he made on Israel
Palestine when he said give them hell I
know that's an easy thing to say and
it's an expression that people use and
they throw it around flippantly but I
think when you actually wish hell upon
other human beings I think it's a
disgusting thing to do because hell is
that 15-year-old girl with no legs and
her parents were dead when you see her
crying her eyes out begging to die that
is hell and I don't think you should
genuinely wish hell on anyone Israel or
Palestinian either anyone I'm a humanist
I don't want anybody to die and when he
was wishing hell on an entire population
he did Express regret for the way he
phrased and he should disgusting I've
not wished hell on the Israelis I've not
wished hell on the Israeli State I don't
want any Israeli civilian to go through
with that 15-year-old Palestinian girl's
going through not a single one he said
about you Jordan Peterson I'm not
particularly happy to be grouped with
Andrew Tate I think there are some
elements about what he does that are
quite reprehensible I'm sure he has I'm
not I don't know everything he says and
he may disagree with some of my points
of view as I said I have nothing against
him I don't think anything he says is
particularly wrong I think that he's
hypocritical because of the
anti-depressant problem and I think that
the fact he wishes hell on other humans
because he gets emotionally involved in
a conflict which within two minutes of
it barking off he's wishing genocide I
think that says a lot about his
personality but overall when he speaks
at length a lot of the things he says
are pretty well thought through and
pretty constructive I nothing against
the guy let me turn to Ben Shapiro he
said let me assure you as someone has
not pimped women and bragged about it
the morality requires that those who
rape women and kidnap women must be
eradicated not negotiated with he says
on my show I won't be lectured on
morality and toughness by Andrew Tate
his great idea of toughness and
moralities pimping women and bragging
about it on air and then trying to quas
he walk it back while simultaneously
maintaining many of the same positions
and flexing his biceps listen everyone
should be able to tweet whatever it is
they want I'm more for an open discourse
even with people who I think are dead
wrong on a lot of issues but Andrew Tate
is dead wrong on a lot of these issues
and the particularly ridiculous
posturing about being a yes you're very
tough when you want people to make peace
with terrorists who just murdered their
children very very tough what do you say
to that so Ben is a warmonger Ben has
been wrong on basically every single
issue you can name he was with you with
the VAC and and every other War Ben is
always calling for other people's young
men to go and die in some War he seems
to love it I don't know if he has short
man syndrome but he's always behind his
desk calling about how important it is
that big strong men like me go and die
and the reason he tweeted that and said
that is because when Hamas in Israel the
very early in the conflict I think it
was three days in we're discussing
possible peace talks he tweeted no
absolutely not them kill them all and I
said I said Ben as a man who's done his
own fighting because I've had a life of
pain and violence listen to me peace is
is always worth a conversation what I
said is that we should always be
prepared to at least discuss peace he
because he's a warmonger said no peace
is not worth the conversation you're
this you're that because he's always
sitting behind his desk he must have a
booster chair and he's always running
his mouth trying to invoke violence and
call for war and I find it kind of
hypocritical because a man who's so
small he would die if he was slapped on
the street sitting behind the desk and
screaming for other people to be
annihilated I think is kind of it's
worse than think I believe I believe if
he was sitting here listening to this he
would say that what he's screaming for
is for Jewish people in Israel be to
defend themselves and he a je does is
call for war and I agree defending
yourself that's all he does that's all
he does and calling for war and call and
defending yourself is very different
than genocide and Ben like I said
overall most of Ben's worldviews and
mine probably align we don't align on
the religious sect we don't rely on the
religious points fine but our overall
worldviews of a how Society should
function probably align on many of the
key issues I'm not I don't have a beef
with Ben and I don't watch his show and
I have no idea what he talks about a lot
of the time but what I do know is every
time I turn it on he's calling for
someone else's son to go and die in a
ditch somewhere for his interests and I
don't like people who are not advocates
for peace blessed are the peacemakers
said kandace who is far more intelligent
than Ben will ever be and she is
completely right he replied that
rhetoric starting an argument with me
when I said we should talk about peace I
say we should talk about peace he calls
for the death of civilians and somehow
we're asking why my point of view is
seen as abstract it's insane why can't
we all just sit down and say the
fighting must end why can't we do that
why can't we sit and say nobody should
be dying let's stop using the most
advanced military weaponry on the planet
to blow the limbs off children why can't
we say that without being deemed some
kind of terrorist sympathizer or
anti-semite it's Insanity Trump came
along and didn't start a single War he's
the only one who didn't and they're
going to come along him and make him a
bad guy when a new president comes in
it's just endless war and death and
killing have you seen a dead body Pierce
have you seen people limb it's
disgusting I know what's happening over
there have you seen I don't need to tell
you about the parts of my history that
I'm not prepared to share Pierce me I
said it to bed I said people who have
done their own fighting and seen their
own violence and have seen people bleed
out in the street from a stab wound are
not going to be so so smart and so quick
to sit behind a desk and call for the
death of innocent people it's disgusting
what's happening I don't want anyone to
die on either side and when I come along
as a peacemaker and say this is insane
because he's a warmonger because he has
chosen blinkers and sees one side of the
argument and refuses to accept the
humanity of Palestinians he says I'm a
bad person for calling for peace well
you know why because he'll probably
listen to this interview and say this
guy can't even describe herass as
terrorist if Ben Shapiro thinks bad and
if you don't think what happen to the
people in Israel October 7th is an act
of terrorism did I not just say I want
all people you are you are just as
partisan to one side as you believe Ben
Shapiro did I not just say I want all
people to start dying stop dying Pierce
don't interrupt this it's two sentences
I want all people to stop dying however
I understand what is going to happen
when you create a pressure cooker that
is my that is my answer and it's
extremely professional I don't want
anyone to die and because I don't want
anyone to die because I'm a peacemaker
because I'm a humanist I understand you
cannot lock people in an open air prison
for an undetermined period of time
without provoking terrorist so out of
Interest what would you have done if
you'd been Israel after October the 7th
that's a really interesting question and
I think there's people who are more
qualified than me to answer given the
Hamas last week said we're going to try
and do the same thing again and again
and again what would you do to defend
the people of Israel good question they
have the Iron Dome which is largely
effective I think that their border
security is usually effective it's very
interesting that it wasn't on the so you
would say they would do nothing other
than tighten up security I think if I
was truthfully I'll answer the question
if I was truthfully in charge of is
Israel I would have found out how our
border was penetrated I would have made
sure that was impossible to do I would
have had large con conversations and
discourse during that period which would
probably take weeks to ensure that my
border was impenetrable because we were
at no genuine threat of a repeat attack
and then I would make it clear that
there will be some repercussion
unless unless there would be some
repercussion unless we can come to peace
terms I don't think theas doesn't want
peace of course not but I'm saying St
position of course of course ask what I
do I would have found out first things
first I'm a man so first things first
you fix the problem okay our Border's
been penetrated how do we make sure that
doesn't happen again how did it happen
internal investigation let's make sure
the border is secure now our civilians
are safe our civilians are safe which
buys us time let's have a conversation
and see if we can actually reason with a
Mas if we can't then there might be a
there might be some military
intervention but there certainly
wouldn't be bombing hospitals Cruise
missling refugee camps there wouldn't be
any of the things was going on now
absolutely not you wouldn't try to
attack the people no because this is a
rushed and emotional response and that's
why I would have prevented I would have
made sure as a man I didn't make a
rushed in emotional respons you you'd be
more like Neville Chamberlain trying to
do peace with the Nazis in Winston
church or trying to kill them well yeah
that's an interesting question you're an
appeaser not a warrior well I still
think I'm a warrior but I think that
when you're a warrior you have to be
very capable and that's what Neville
Chamberlain's view was we we should do
peace with the Nazis you have to be very
understanding of your power and you have
to use it responsibil responsibly and
just like I said earlier when I'm trying
to be responsible about what I say to
the young men of the world I would
understand as Israel I must be
responsible with my massive military
might to make sure I don't kill
civilians and I would sit and try and
make a measured response and I'd be a
professional and I would consider them
human beings and I would secure my
border and try and come up with a plan
better than oh no I'm mad I'm emotional
now let's go kill everyone I think
that's the wrong response correct I
don't think I don't think that's the
right thing to do we've spent a long
time talking um you're going to find out
at some stage today or in the next few
days whether you're going to get your
possessions back that'll either happen
or not happen but then there's likely to
be a try
and that will determine how you spend
the next 10 years of your life almost
certainly which is a sobering thought
for anyone when you look back on the
whole Arc of the last few years you know
you've expressed some regret because of
your turning to Islam your change in in
your philosophy from a religious
perspective you've acknowledged that
some of the stuff you used to do was
immoral do you look at the journey
you've gone on here and think that in a
way not with understanding The Matrix
and everything else that maybe you
yourself could have done things
differently to avoid being in this
position AB absolutely I'm a man and I
take absolute self-accountability you
have to as a man your superpower is
looking in the mirror and understanding
everything that happens to you both good
and bad to a degree is your fault it
could have all been influenced I could
have avoided all of this I could have
avoided The Matrix attacks or sorry I
could have avoided jail cell if you
don't let me using that term I could
have avoided all the negative press I
could have chosen to work in Starbucks
and just stay to nobody I made choices
that put me in this position I I take
responsibility for them I said things on
the internet in a satirical way on
videos that got 110 views when YouTube
was brand new that I did not expect to
become the most viral videos in the
world because I didn't expect to become
the most vamous and known person on the
planet that's all true I'm not saying I
have no part to play in any of this
however I can still say that I'm
completely innocent I can still say that
is only my fame and notoriety that has
inspired the prosecution service to try
and even put me in jail in the first
place I can still say that there's some
unfair policing in the world depending
on your political views I can still say
all of those things while accepting
Absolut responsibility for the situation
I am in Andrew Tate thank you very much
thank you
sir on S of next Andrew Tate's brother
and Confidant Tristan who's facing the
same criminal charges in Romania speaks
to me exclusively for the first time he
said the times I struck a woman brackets
in passion I never left a mark I've
never heard that before in my
life we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to useing XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bra she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fast or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about1 140 million £140
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the jemy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man mc
mouseman mc he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology a
party political broadcast on behalf of
the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
imp power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
Tristan first of all your reaction to
that extraordinary interview I just
finish with your brother I think that
was one of the best interviews ever
conducted with Andrew I actually I don't
know how hard you're going to go on me
so perhaps I'm making a mistake saying
this I like how you challenge your
guests I like how you seem to have a
very impartial opinion on people you
don't judge things one way or another
before you go into the interviews and I
think that made the interview with
Andrew very interesting I'm I'm very
excited to see the public response I
mean like I said to him I'm not here to
to convict you or otherwise I don't know
if you're guilty or not of the charges
LED against you will establish that in a
trial or otherwise I mean it may not
even go to trial no it I not rolling
stone in a profile uh said this about
Rolling Stone their relationship Dynamic
is very odd it's like Tristan is held
captive by Andrew and believes or
follows everything Andrew says or does I
don't believe or follow a lot of things
that Andrew says or does um um you know
I get asked every single day to counter
EJ Dickinson is This Woman's name I
could tell you some horrible stories
about the people who she's harassed and
bothered this Rolling Stone woman um the
things Andrew says and does I mean I get
asked what don't you like about his
views well the the major one the major
one when people say oh Tristan now that
you've converted to Islam I'm like I
haven't converted to Islam who says I
converted to Islam No I'm an Orthodox
Christian I've have not converted to
Islam what do you think of his
conversion I think that it's a it's not
my place to even comment on it now some
of the greatest religious discussions
I've had have been with Andrew since his
reversion since him reading the Quran
most of it of which he covered in in
prison and we sit there and discuss
these various ideas but I believe that
individual religious conviction is
exactly that it's individual and I don't
believe whether I'm his brother whether
I'm his son mother Uncle I have no place
to tell him what his religious
conviction should be just as he has no
business to tell me mine so I'm I'm
happy for him because he's become a
happier and better person are you
Rivals um yes oh absolutely but in the
best and most healthy way I can't watch
him train in the gym for an hour in the
morning and then not train for an hour
myself I can't sit there drinking and
relaxing and partying while he's on his
laptop working you ever fight no never
we never argue you never physically
fight well we used to physically fight
all the time we're both professional
athletes so we used to beat each other
up in the in the ring for sparring who
would win oh Andrew would win um I was
good I was the European champion at my
Peak but Andrew was built for Andrew was
I mean see my broken nose it leans this
way first time it was broken was by him
and it got weaker after that and I had
it broken twice subsequently and kic
boxing matches but yeah we we are rivals
in the way that we Inspire each other to
work better and to be better but not
rivals in any way that his success would
upset me or my success would upset him
when you were in jail together yes so a
period of that three months you were
actually in the same cell indeed for
about half of it what did you what did
you talk about when it's just you and
him and you're thinking we may never get
out of
it ah lots of things books religion the
case obviously um explaining trying to
understand and a cockroach infested tiny
cell together yes you've gone from being
the top G and his brother with your
Bugattis your cigars the the lifestyle
the women and so on to literally nothing
in a very degrading environment you find
yourself in and you've got no idea how
this plays out or How It Ends or even if
you get out I mean that's a pretty
that's a big
moment yeah I guess it's uh it is a big
moment but I always knew that we were
going to be okay you know even when I
was separate from him I wasn't worried
that he was banging his head against the
wall or self Haring or doing anything
stupid again he wasn't worried about me
uh we obviously weren't worried that the
other brother and I know you can't share
in this conviction I know he's not a
criminal I know he has no skeletons in
his closet and no criminal past he knows
exactly the same about me so we were
very relaxed um I guess in jail I was
more relaxed than I am now because in
prison I assumed that the prosecutor
whose job by the Romanian Constitution
by the way he's not a district attorney
like in the United States where he is
told he has to argue that you're guilty
and that's it the prosecutor's job
actually here is to discern the truth of
the situation so I was sitting in jail
relatively relaxed thinking well this is
going to end any day now I mean human
trafficking this is this is stupid it's
not going to happen like not going to
sentence me to jail for this it was only
when I got out that I learned the true
motivations behind this that made me
actually more worried than I was in jail
so in jail I was relatively relaxed
trained every day ate their horrible
food did my push-ups was all right
mental break no
electronics people often say and it's
certainly true from people I've
interviewed over the years that you're a
product of your environment particularly
of your parents yes in a November 2011
Facebook post your father Emory wrote
that the Eternal problem of the alpha
male was protecting his flock of women
he said the times I struck a woman
brackets in passion I never left a mark
no Trace hyper contr control super
control of a human animal they love me
still um I've never heard that before in
my life I'm smiling man because I can I
can imagine his voice saying it um you
can I can imagine his voice saying it
the only times I've struck a woman in
Brackets in passion have you ever struck
a woman in passion Pierce no you haven't
no not a little
spank well once let's let's keep this
above board but I want to Pi but I'm
saying like I understand how you're
trying to phrase this no I I don't
understand my father's dead and I'm I'm
not trying to phrase it in anyway I'm
just curious what you think you meant by
that um I I honestly don't know I mean
keep in mind my father died when I was
27 and that post was written a long time
ago never heard it before I've never
seen it before what kind of father was
he in terms of the values he instilled
in you and Andrew oh he was a wonderful
man and he was a very protective man
over his family and the people he cared
about uh I mean they haven't they they
got divorced many many years ago but
even with his dying breath he would have
jumped in to fight 10 men to defend my
mother in her honor um that's the kind
of guy he was super protective and super
you know involved in everyone he loves
life even if he was far away you know
the phone calls were were constant the
emails were constant and he held us very
accountable as young men Andrew tweeted
last year my dad was a chess genius CIA
operative my mother was a dinner lady
they had nothing in common dad said she
fed you boys healthy meals every day
cleaned the house and was largely quiet
I loved her very much that's literally
all men
want is that are you asking if that's an
accurate description of my parents
relationship yeah perhaps yeah but my
mother was a wonderful mother see I
don't I don't think but they spit they
spit up of course of course they did but
that does well so when he says that's
literally all men one they split up way
before I was old enough to understand
marriage or sexual or male or female
Dynamics by the way so I can't even
comment on their marriage what I can
comment on is how they were as parents
and what I will say is I don't look back
on my childhood raised in a council of
State uh on state benefits you know I
was free school lunches I don't look
back on that and think oh my mother was
a terrible mother because we didn't have
any money because I don't think it was
my mother's job to to I guess provide as
much as my father was doing his best
from the United States but I will look
back and say my mother was an absolutely
wonderful mother I had three Square
meals a day um she knew how to M manage
her finances didn't smoke didn't go out
with her friends uh made sure my clothes
were always washed knew how to mend
things she was a she is how does she
feel about the fact both her boys are in
this serious legal Jeopardy well you
have to understand she's known us our
entire our entire lives and you haven't
you know when I was 15 16 18 all my
friends were selling drugs and breaking
into cars I was down at the kickboxing
gym every single day I would get into
the kickboxing ring for 50 after 8 weeks
training just because I found Harmony in
the discipline that sport gave me I
think kickboxing is massively largely
responsible for keeping me from ever
doing anything illegal never tried a
drug in my life uh never broken a law in
my life never broken any law speeding
you know feel I mean we're talking I'm
talking about serious crimes and my
mother's known that even at my most
desperate and my most poor I would come
home to her and sleep on her couch for
six months as opposed to do anything
illegal and try to find an honest good
way of uh legal way at least of making
money so the idea she she worried about
you the situation you're in well she's
not she's worried about the situation
but she has no no doubt in her mind that
I haven't done any heinous things
against women especially for money
because it doesn't make sense that after
going through what I've gone through and
avoiding any legal problems suddenly I'm
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and I decide that's the time to start
trafficing you guys have preached a
message of masculinity and I'm all in
favor of masculinity great many other
people have categorized it as toxic
masculinity because of the misogyny and
so on do you feel that maybe you have
collectively gone too far in the
misogyny and that has been again one of
the reasons you find yourself in the
problems you're in well again when I say
first the kind of alpha male well what
if I retor what have I said that's
misogynic I'm just asking you generally
whether you feel that's part of the
problem I don't I don't think that's
part of the problem I don't think it is
a problem at all I think that when
somebody has speak been speaking on the
internet for a decade you have to
understand that first of all lots and
lots of content is produced and it's
very easy to cherry-pick and to take
things out of context and number two the
man speaking on the internet 10 years
ago is not the man sitting in being
interviewed by you today you know who I
was when I was 25 I fancied myself a bit
of a dating coach used to give people
advice on how to meet women and how to
pick that's not how I Live Now I'm 35
I'm not 25 you at 25 I'm sure we're very
vastly different than you are today
so you know I don't think there's a
problem with anything I've said cuz I've
never advocated for anything illegal
I've never advocated for any crime I do
not advocate for drugs I do not advocate
for violence I do not advocate for any
of these things so if Andrew said that
women can't drive as well as men once
like it's very easy to jump on that and
say this man is the world's biggest
misogynist because he said X look I just
think it's for me when I look at all the
rhetoric the stuff that I find most
problematic to use the phrase of the the
buzz phrase of our era absolutely is
simply where I feel like if it Strays
into that misogyny I think you let
yourselves down that you have you have a
good message in many ways you know a lot
of the stuff not withstanding the
serious charges you're facing and we'll
have to see how that all plays out and
maybe you both are very different people
to the ones you're claiming to be we'll
find out right but in terms of your
general rhetoric I find that constant
running underpinning theme of misogyny
and about where A Woman's Place should
be that is the problem in terms of the
influence on young men they shouldn't
all be walking around thinking that A
Woman's Place is only in the home
serving their men and that somehow their
only thought process each day women
should be how do I please my man not can
I get a fulfilling job or any of those
things but no you stay at home
self-improvement make yourself look good
obey his instructions all that kind of
stuff Andrew talking about the way that
he wants his relationships to work not
it's not he's entitled to what
advocating and forcing the whole world
to see yeah but that's the delusion
because well no because he can you can
say he only wants that for himself right
by the way he's allowed any relationship
he wants but when do you pretend that
when he says those things they're not
Amplified to literally tens of millions
of impressible young men but here's why
you're wrong then you know that's not
true well here's why you're wrong
because you assume that Andrew tapate
for some reason in this conversation is
the only influencer in the world and the
only people person people listen to CU
he's not at all the internet I got to
tell you he's one of the most
influential no he absolutely is and
that's great and that's the part of
that's the part of his influence that I
think is a potentially and it's
wonderful and good and you don't have to
like it but let me tell you each every
Force has an equal and opposite Force
somewhere else so on on X uh Elon has
now legalized free speech on that
platform so there are differing opinions
on every single um on every single
aspect of life including how you want to
date women what kind of music you should
listen to what kind of cars are good
what kind of whatever it is so for every
Andrew Tate out there there's some
feminist only fans model who lives in
Florida who makes rap music who's saying
that men are nothing and men are so so
the people who are listening to Andrew T
aren't listening to Andrew T they're
listening to the internet as a whole and
I believe Andrew's message is one
overwhelmingly positive absolutely
overwhelmingly positive and I believe
he's a very important mark on that
spectrum of opinions that exist out
there because when you delete Andrew
Tate the mean average of people will
drift down this toilet of degeneracy and
become less like Andrew Tate he's a
professional athlete with a with a
completely clean criminal record by the
way um who's massively financially suc
uccessful who's kind who's generous he
runs his own charity he's the best
brother he's the best father he's the
best uncle he's an absolutely wonderful
man I would love to see more men become
like him so I like his opinions and I
like the fact that he's out there
Tristan
Tate thank you it's been a pleasure it
wasn't until I got to Ukraine where I
really felt like now I understand this
thing you dedicated the film to Ukraine
in fighted pilot and he very sadly died
three months ago yeah in a training
exercise yeah the Israel Hamas War
Israel also has a prime minister who is
a terror Will Smith Chris Rock punch up
on stage a very low moment we're in a
world where cancel culture is a very
real thing I have opinions big
[Music]
surprise
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costum criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about to all today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other reuff
usually very dull this one had booster
Rockets attached to it certainly the
tone has shifted in terms of what rashak
has done the question now is what he
does next the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk to sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom